The Joe Rogan experience. All right, cool.
So we were just talking about your books
and I tried, I said, let's save it.
Let's save it for the podcast
because I wanted it to sound fresh.
I want you to reset. So tell
me about, you wrote two books.
I wrote two books and you know,
as you know, I'm a, you know,
movie writer and a movie and television
producer said mildly. I mean,
I made some fucking amazing movies. Wow.
Thanks. Thanks Joe. My pleasure. Yeah.
And um, uh, and all this, I think,
you know, uh,
my whole life and whatever those stories
are the movies are and the successes,
I kinda think anyone that's really
focused can, can do what I do.
So that was kind of the end product
of the first book, which was,
it was called a curious mind,
the secret to bigger life.
And um, that book is really about,
I mean, how much do you want to know
about it and everything? Everything. Okay.
So basically I couldn't read it all in
elementary school and it caused a lot of
trauma, a lot of shame. And then a
lot of trauma. Did you have dyslexia?
I had dyslexia, very,
very quite acute dyslexia.
And I think we're out in Woodland Hills,
which was the fancy part of the Valley.
I grew up in the flats of
Sherman Oaks. Uh, actually as a,
as a little kid going to Riverside drive
elementary school and then later to
Nobel junior high and then
later Chatsworth high school.
And in elementary school
I couldn't read it all.
And they didn't classify it as
dyslexia that it was just your slow,
you're dumb. You, uh, why can't you
answer this? Uh, and then you'd say,
I can't read. And then
that didn't make sense.
It just didn't see none of
those things computed really,
that somebody couldn't actually read a
word and I really couldn't read a word.
So when you can't read a word,
then you find ways to uh, survive, cope,
um, and not have the teacher
look you in the eyes and say,
okay Brian,
come to the board and answer this question
because you're never just going to
produce more shame cause you're
not, you don't know the answer.
It's not possible. So I found that, um,
as that went on for a little while, for
quite a while around the fourth, fifth,
sixth grade, I really looked at people,
I really looked them in the eyes to learn.
And I've found that by looking
somebody in the eyes, you could engage,
I didn't know this then,
but you engage their heart.
If you're really doing it
with sincerity and interest,
you can engage people and move
them and evangelize things young,
get people to like play on your
team and or you play on their team,
they pick you and stuff. Good things
happen. Um, except the reading part.
Um, but it,
it enabled me to learn a lot just by
looking at people and talking to people.
And my, I had this one mentor,
this little grandmother, uh,
her name was Sonya and a
little Sonia. She's like
four, 10, I guess, you know.
And she would always say to me,
she'd see me once a week, minimally,
always once a week, and she'd
say, you're going all the way,
you're going to make it
big, think big, be big.
And she had all these isms because a
half my mom's side of the family was
Jewish. My dad's side of the
family's Catholic, the Jewish side,
the grandmother was my mentor.
And the worst thing that really was the
single person that I could kind of count
on in life. And she'd constantly tell
me how, how things, I'd go, great.
You have a gift for gab, she'd
say, and, and every time she said,
you're gonna go all the way.
I'm thinking there's like
absolutely no empirical evidence.
I'm going all the way anywhere except
my parents were always arguing,
let's put him back. The teacher,
miss STIGs had, let's put him back.
So I just wasn't going
anywhere. I didn't think so.
So that gave rise to me,
give rise to the fact that I thought
the way I can really learn a lot is have
these kind of curiosity conversations.
And once I graduated college,
I did this on a weekly basis.
And if still do it to this day,
once a week, sometimes
once every two weeks,
but never more than once every two
weeks. I never, I'm pretty militant.
I'm extremely militant about it. Like
how do you do it? Like what do you mean?
Um, well what I do is I think
about, it's often, and I,
I know you do something possibly
similar to this and, and, and,
but my system would be,
I bombard myself with,
now I can read of course. Um,
and I was able to start to
read like in high school,
can you tell me how they fix that?
They couldn't fix it. It's not,
it wasn't fixable. How to dyslexia
reverses words on you, right?
Uh, versus the way you view letters
and, yeah. Well, it's scary.
Initially as a kid it's
scrambles the letters.
Then when it gets better,
it reverses the words.
And to this day I still start
on the right and go to the left.
So it takes like really thoughtful,
disciplined to make sure
I'm always starting.
Do you mean with the sentences or the
sentences with a sentence? Really.
So you'll start at the right end of the,
you should read Hebrew or something.
Isn't that different languages
do that, right? Yeah,
I guess they do. Um,
but incidentally when you have dyslexia
it's very hard to learn other languages.
So I would imagine
very, very hard. So, um,
but I can read and I bombard myself.
So how do you switch it around?
Like when, when your, your brain is
making you read right to left? Yes.
Um, I, I, I started to learn, just
create like, just like an exercise,
a discipline where I could,
like in K as in college,
I was able to read,
I get forced myself to start on
the left and go to the right.
Is there a certain mechanism that's
causing you to do right? To laugh?
Like do they know what the cause
of this is? Not that I know of. Hm.
Not that I know. Probably something
neurological and certainly genetic.
I mean I have no genetic trace, but it
has to be a letter within your genome.
I have to get, having to guess.
So you learned how to read,
you learned how to figure it
out. And then you said you,
you have these conversations
at least once every two weeks.
So how do you do this? Like, what
do you do? You organize them,
they're structured, they're
structured. They, they, they're,
they see there's a randomness to
them because often you'd have to,
I have to,
it's not like getting on your show where
everybody wants to be in the show. Uh,
I say that with a compliment of
course, but I, I'm begging people you,
because even though down with you,
I'm begging him to sit down with
me and I'm groveling and uh,
I'm calling assistance directly.
I still, I have three assistants,
but I make all of my own phone
calls always. You know, why?
Because I have this discipline of getting
to know assistance and going, Hey,
it's Brian is Richard around
or, and I just like, I do that.
That's so refreshing from a guy who's
as successful as you are because so many
times when people get that successful,
you insulate yourself with a bunch of
other people that do all the calls for you
and open all the doors for
you and you just kinda,
you stay insulated and
more aloof. Yeah. Thanks.
Well, thank you. Thanks. Well, I,
yeah, they do. People do. I mean look,
there are producers that are
sort of, that are, you know,
let's say we're in the same category,
same ill that just do it differently. I,
I made a lot of deliberate
choices through trial and error.
I saw,
I went through the 80s where power guys
had desks above the other chairs that
are on the other side.
I have the power guys always had black
lacquer furniture and they did all these
power things. And I thought, I want to re,
I want artists to like me relate to me.
And I always did everything to create a
democratic environment because not that
I was such a cool guy,
but more like you just get so much
more out of a creative person by not
intimidating them. Sure. Yeah.
And I just saw, you know,
my peers and sometimes often, you know,
someone maybe a decade ahead of me,
you know, I don't want to say I'm
so close to saying names, but,
but just those sort of tough
guys, you know? Um, and I,
I didn't think that was an effective,
I just didn't think it was effective.
And I wasn't making these
really hardcore action movies.
I was doing movies that were,
they're designed to a mite,
a ignite emotion and feeling. In fact,
even when I do public speaking, I say, Oh,
Brian Grazer dead or whatever
they might say. But I goes, I'm,
I always say I'm in the feelings
business. I'm not a movie producer,
so I'm just a,
I'm in the feelings business because I
feel like that's what we want out of a
cinematic experience for me. Sure.
The movies I'm interested in
doing or TV shows is that,
so, um, because I,
I grew up loving those movies in the 70s
and I'm captivated by things that move
me emotionally and elevate me emotional.
So you make these phone calls and
you arrange these conversations.
So you arrange basically a
podcast that no one's listening to
that's kind of like you. That's exactly,
I never thought of it in those
words. That is really funny.
You should probably record them.
I S so I've done it for say,
35 years. Really?
You didn't record any of them
the first 15 years and nothing.
I didn't write no really notes either.
And then the second 10
years that was, you know,
I'd say 15 was nothing.
I just did it cause I felt like that could
inhibit somebody or I felt like I was
trying to do these sort
of down low in a way.
Like I didn't want to
commodify them, you know,
like industrialized by conversations
and I had friends go like, Oh,
can we be part of it? And I tried
it once with a couple other guys.
It during my thing and it
fractionalized or my attention. Yeah.
And it, it, when I found the great
thing about the conversations,
the one on one with no one else in the
room, which that's all I do. Again, I've,
I tried it different
ways. It, it create your,
what's you're trying to do,
I'm trying to do is like create the best
date that Isaac Asimov I've had had or,
or you know, or I mean I have so
many people, you know, just uh,
Margaret Thatcher. I'm
trying to, like, I'm,
I'm trying to be,
have no idea of a time and space and I
want them to have no idea of time and
space and because that
is like your best date.
And I always think like my, what is
my best date with a girl? My very,
for me Brian, cause I,
I, I, my best date is,
I'm not even thinking about time
and it's just becomes almost like a,
a biochemical event. It's
just things are evolving.
And I felt like I could do this with
Nobel, with many Nobel laureates,
with Sheldon glass cow who converted
the four forces of Daisy nation, uh,
uh, of, of nature to three. And I
brought his name up because, uh,
well first of all, I knew
that your show, you could,
you could do whatever you want. And,
and was Sheldon Glasgow? It's like,
I usually do an hour or two hours,
but I hung out with this guy,
shut up my whole day
down for six hours. Wow.
Just because I was so captivated by him
and he talked about multiple subjects.
So basically I am always got somebody
that I'm really wanting to meet and it's
takes a year at least or
sometimes years to organize this,
to get them to say yes or to be in the
same city or be willing to say yes and
meek flight in New York
or some other place.
It sounds like you have figured out
the benefit that I've experienced from
having podcasts and having these
kinds of conversations one on one
conversations,
but you did it just for your
own personal edification.
Yeah, it's, it's kind
of amazing, but it's,
I have gotten more out of talking
to people like this and it's,
it made me grow more as a person and make,
made me understand more
about communication and
how to talk to people than
anything I've ever done in my whole life.
Because you don't normally
have this completely unfilled.
It's one of the reasons why I like
headsets as well because it locks you in.
It's like your,
your volume of you talking is the same
level in my ears as it is in your ears.
We're all on this one. It's not
like there's distance between us.
We're in each other's ears and
we're talking, there's no phones,
there's no nothing. We're
sitting across from each other.
How would I ever organize this?
I had thought about that with so many
different people that I've had a chance to
talk to. Like how would
I ever get Sean Carroll,
the astrophysicist says to sit down and
just talk to me for three hours to count
against him. I would never get him to
do that. I would never get them to, Hey,
let's put headphones on and you just
tell me about stuff like explained to me
about no one, no one would ever do that.
But because of this
thing called the podcast,
because I can share it with all the
other people that are listening.
I've had this chance to have these kinds
of conversations and it sounds like
you've done the same thing, but without
an audience. That's really brilliant.
It's a brilliant way that you figured
out that this is a great way to, to,
to expand your own understanding of
people by being one on one with these
brilliant folks. Yes,
exactly. And, and, um,
and maybe you do this too,
but I, I've found, I mean,
I do meet a lot of people. I reach out
to me people that are, you know, expert.
Um, it's many different things
that I, that I don't do, of course.
But sometimes I just,
I become really motivated just to meet
somebody because they're so uniquely
committed to something.
They're so obsessed. Yes. Um,
and I've even found that I've learned a
lot from Uber drivers and baristas and
stuff where I, um, so I, I,
but I do reach out to meet, you know,
people that have really
had a very intense,
committed to a really intense
journey and often have triumphed in
[inaudible].